de la hausse du prix du gaz les prix de
ces deux énergies étant lié au sein du
marché européen de l'énergie
cette situation constitue vous l'avez
bien compris une menace réelle alors que
les cours du gaz ont été multipliées par
7 en six mois et pour le pouvoir d'achat
des consommateurs français et européens
les français d'abord c'est à la fois
dangereux et injuste puisque notre pays
à une conne une production électrique
très largement décarbonée pour des coûts
de production peu élevés au demeurant la
la non prise en compte de la part des
énergies renouvelables dans la formation
des prix de l'électricité n'est pas sans
poser problème et n'incite pas au
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
c'est finalement un comble par
conséquent il revient aux 27 états
membres de faire le point et de décider
des actions à mettre en oeuvre au niveau
européen mais également au niveau
national pour faire face à la flambée
des prix l'énergie l'une des priorités
est évidemment de réduire la facture à
la fois pour les ménages et pour les
entreprises les états restent en
première ligne pour se faire grâce à des
mesures ciblées sur les ménages modestes
c'est l'objet du chèque énergie mais
également grâce à des mesures fiscales
notamment est encouragée par la
commission européenne
je note que cette dernière a aujourd'hui
même communiqué en évoquant une boîte à
outils pour faire face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie elle préconise et leur
encourage notamment les mesures
nationales
temporaire pour limiter l'impact de la
hausse des prix sur les ménages le
gouvernement propose ainsi ce qu'il
appelle un bouclier tarifaire
constitué d'un gel des tarifs
réglementés du gaz et d'une baisse de
taxe sur l'électricité
les mesures d'accompagnement des
fournisseurs qui pourraient faire face à
des difficultés de trésorerie ces
prochains mois paraissent néanmoins
insuffisantes à ce stade
plus globalement
je ne vois guère à cet instant de
réponse précise apporter aux entreprises
qui elles aussi subissent de plein fouet
la au détail de l'énergie je signale qu
aujourd'hui la commission européenne a
incité les états membres à soutenir
leurs entreprises et leurs industries en
faisant usage des mesures
d'assouplissement exceptionnelle du
régime des aides d'état
alors monsieur le ministre gouvernement
at il prévu de suivre cette suggestion
cette préconisation et de renforcer son
soutien aux professionnels depuis
maintenant quelques semaines les états
prennent donc des mesures en ordre
dispersé dans un marché pourtant intégré
comme celui d'énergie à l'aube de
l'hiver et alors qu'on assiste à une
véritable guerre d'approvisionnement il
est grand temps de mettre davantage de
coordination dans les mesures proposées
l'europe qui protège slogan souvent
utilisée par le prénom un public doit de
notre point de vue contribuer à assurer
la sécurité énergétique de nos
concitoyens la souveraineté européenne
est une expression à la mode alors
monsieur le ministre
l'indépendance énergétique de l'union
européenne doit désormais constituer une
priorité que la france devra s'attacher
à défendre lors de sa présidence du
conseil de l'union européenne
à vous désormais monsieur ministre
d'être au rendez vous je vous remercie
la précarité énergétique explose on l'a
dit le rapport du médiateur de l'énergie
qui vient d'être publié les value pour
notre pays à une famille sur cinq un
jeune sur trois à l'échelle de l'union
se sont déjà plusieurs dizaines de
millions d'européens qui n'était pas en
mesure de chauffer convenablement leur
logement et cet hiver l'inflation des
prix de l'électricité du gaz menace de
faire des dégâts sociaux encore plus
considérable sortir des millions
d'européens de la précarité énergétique
voilà qui doit être une priorité claire
de ce conseil européen et une telle
unité m'appliquer effectivement une
action coordonnée à tous les niveaux
au-delà des aides des états ciblés sur
les ménages les plus précaires ne nous
trompons pas de stratégie la trajectoire
de consommation énergétique responsable
c'est la sobriété
l'efficacité énergétique la rénovation
thermique n'en déplaise à ceux qui vous
vous levez en faire croire que de
nouveaux programmes nucléaires
nourrirait à l'avenir la gabegie et la
croissance énergétique dont ils ne
seraient pas impératif de sortir non
économies d'énergie déploiement des
renouvelables de plus en plus compétitif
avancée pour le stockage de
l'électricité là sont les leviers d'un
avenir durable la marche vers la
neutralité carbone effective ne
s'enclenchera pas avec des paroles ou
avec des jeux pertes au tall man hors de
prix et des promesses vagues de mini
réacteurs la sobriété et les
renouvelables sont aujourd'hui les
leviers fiable de la transition ne
sabotons pas les chances de réussir
cette transition énergétique
industrielle en cherchant à faire passer
en europe le gaz et le nucléaire comme
des énergies d'avenir comme des énergies
vertes le débat d'ailleurs à ce sujet au
parlement européen montre bien combien
le discours actuel de votre gouvernement
et rétrograde sur cette question mes
chers collègues comme vous le savez
cette évolution salutaire à deux
vitesses induit également des pressions
inflationnistes
j'aime bien ici la question du prix de
l'énergie qui sera au menu du prochain
conseil européen
le prix du gaz sert à un shérif de 50 %
sur un an une évolution qui accapare le
débat public depuis quelques semaines
compte tenu de son impact en matière
sociale économique et environnementale
si les états membres doivent prendre des
mesures nationales pour aider les
ménages modestes il est clair que dans
ce domaine là aussi la coordination
européenne a également dû sens comme l'a
d'ailleurs souligné le commissaire à
l'économie mais il va falloir s'entendre
tous les états membres ne souhaitent pas
la même chose je note que kddi simpson
bien consciente des divergences a
surtout annoncé ce matin la possibilité
pour les européens de prendre des
mesures temporaires oui il faut mettre
en place des baisses de taxes oui il
faut pratiquer la tolérance zéro à
l'égard des spéculateurs
cependant à plus long terme queen de
lits des réserves stratégiques de gaz
avancée par l'espagne doit-on aussi
changer les règles du marché européen de
l'énergie comme le souhaite la france
et il en est fait normal que le prix de
l'énergie soit le même pour tous que les
pays fassent ou non des efforts pour
décarbonés son économie l'alignement des
prix énergétiques sur celui du vin se
pose un vrai problème
quoi qu'il en soit tout cela ne résoudra
pas la dépanneuse de l'union européenne
qui importe 90% de son gas et 97 % du
pétrole
dans ces conditions on ne peut que
rejoindre la côte la commission qui
demande aux états membres l'accélération
de la transition vers des énergies
propres
[Musique]